oh playing jerry again
what does jerry play against stafford
i don't think jerry goes into stafford
unless he does
he does wow
oh he knows what to do as well let's
play b5
and then a5
let's go
and then bishop e6 and go for b4
so this is a
playable line
oh almost pre-moved a brook blunder
okay at least i'm getting some
sort of position
it's remotely playable
so staffer gambit against jerry
i don't think i've i can't remember if i
played stafford against him before
it's kind of working though
oh it's really working
[Music]
that worked out really nicely
yeah
i mean he played the best line this uh
this h3 move best move in this
position but uh okay still got some play
made things spicy
what about g4 oh you mean g5 wait is g5
a move
wait a minute
i saw just an offhand comment
g
i think you mean g5
g5 would be really funny actually
is g5 playable
i played b5 which has been like a
move a pet move of mine
oh it's kind of playable
like okay computer loves white but g5
doesn't make it so much worse
i assume the idea would be g4 that's
actually kind of cool
bishop c4
oh bishop c4 then b5
oh this is also cool
bishop b3
and then g4 maybe i'll play this next
time
next chance i get
with bishop e2
wow bishop e2 runs into queen d4
if rook f1 we win the pawn of castling
then there's some fun attack g wait g4
well this is actually really cool
because bishop e2 i feel like is pretty
human
okay played three times with d3
and we have to play rook
g8
thank you to whoever who was that that
was trey chass
oh trey chess says it's tricky i have
played it
yeah i like the spirit of this this idea
because you just want to go for a g4 and
get your knight in
yeah i think i'll uh i'll try this next
time g5 it's never a move that has come
to mind
[Music]
183 playing mr fire human
never played before
okay so this is my new move g5
and then queen d4 oh okay so this first
time getting this sort of trap if takes
the only thing i remember is h5 and
engine prefers black
this is new stafford prep
that i learned last night
it was actually really cool
take and open the file
now there's a funny idea it might happen
if bishop e3 i forced mate with rook h1
yeah wow this is such a nice game
it's new stafford crap
this is how you refute this so-called
refutation
because there's so many videos on
youtube showing h3 and just like kills
the stafford
but new move g5
and i only discovered it like
what a few hours ago
or maybe like
20 hours ago
[Music]
but uh yeah it's been it's been in emote
form for a while
and then this is uh just to show the
analysis
like engine still prefers white but
after it takes h5 is uh
it's already very dangerous
and then this is a cool mating idea
queen h8
okay i might have to put that on my
youtube main channel
just like a quick
little tidbit
shout out to the clips channel if you
want more short form content
i'll leave a link below
or you can use the clips command in
twitch chat